[Música]
cuando tenía 15 años una tía psicóloga
me dijo que por favor le ayudara a
montar una presentación de power point
de un caso clínico mi tía no sabía mucho
de power point yo por mi edad si lo
manejaba mejor y perfecto decide
ayudarla y cuando decidió ayudarla me
encuentro con que el tópico es el duelo
patológico y a través de los casos
clínicos vi lo duro que es para los
seres humanos las pérdidas o renunciar a
cosas que teníamos y que hay muchas
cosas no solamente personas sino que hay
muchos espacios donde se generan duelo
muchos puntos que se cierran y ciclos
que se abren y además me imaginé que
esto me ayudaría tanto a entendernos
frente a la crisis mi nombre es veronica
soy el viso y hoy quiero hablarles de
como las crisis generan un nuevo ciclo o
una nueva oportunidad
a mis 17 años mi mamá entra en un coma
inducido pasó treinta y tantos días en
coma
yo soy hermana mayor mi papá vivía en
eeuu no vivía conmigo en mi país en
venezuela no tengo vuelos habían
fallecido más pronto en mi vida solo una
abuela materna que es muy importante
pero vivía en otra ciudad éramos mi
hermano y yo y yo le llevo cuatro años a
mi hermano en ese momento que mi mamá
pasa por por su enfermedad y que era tan
crítica su situación yo pese a pensar
bueno si los médicos comienzan a decir
que hay una posibilidad de que mi ama se
despierte qué va a pasar cuando mi mamá
se despierte y la despidan de su trabajo
resulta que en esos días de como
inducido de mi mamá yo pensaba son
muchos días sin asistir al trabajo y
para ese entonces el trabajo de mi mamá
era remoto porque mi mamá era la alta
ejecutivo de un distribuidor de
productos de materia prima para
laboratorios farmacéuticos con
era la representante en venezuela mi
mamá hacía todo desde una oficina en
casa donde atendía las órdenes de compra
y las ventas y las negociaciones con los
laboratorios resulta que yo ya había
vivido una crisis de mi mamá hay una
crisis en mi casa cuando fue en
venezuela hubo el paro petrolero se
paralizaron muchísimas empresas y al
paralizarse esas empresas mi mamá quedó
sin trabajo y yo viví de cerca la crisis
de mi mamá de haber vivido uno de sus
duelos haber dejado de ser una alta
ejecutiva ahora entender que iba a ser
porque su trabajo la definía mucho en
ese entonces lo que ella hacía y el
nivel de rol que ella tenía eso era lo
que ella era y haber pasado por el duelo
renunciar a eso nos hizo vivir en casa
situaciones muy críticas y estando luego
yo sentada en esa sala de espera de la
terapia intensiva esperando a ver si mi
mamá respondía yo pensaba y ahora como
mi mamá va a vivir el duelo de volver a
haber perdido su trabajo
su condición respiratoria porque ya
tenía un efisema iun además pulmonar
entonces yo dije algo tengo que hacer y
ese es el primer descubrimiento que he
visto de cómo reaccionó yo frente a la
crisis genera en mí un sentido de
urgencia importante de involucrarme con
la situación no dejar que la crisis
solamente como si fuera una ola me lleve
me revuelquen la orilla sino que yo
siento que tengo que ser parte tengo que
ensuciar mis manos en la crisis porque
no hacer nada frente a una situación
crítica lo único que mi cabeza piensa es
si no hacemos nada y ya es crítico la
tendencia va a ser a que tiende a
empeorar y yo solamente por evitar que
empeore siento urgencia por ser parte de
la crisis y que hice entonces en ese
momento bueno decidí hacerme pasar por
mi mamá en su trabajo remoto si a mis 17
años abrí el computador de mi mamá
revise todas las carpetas revisar los
mails en los emails en outlook y veía
como ya negociaba con
oratorio más o menos siempre pedían lo
mismo y más o menos eran los mismas
órdenes de compra sólo había que hacerle
seguimiento a los clientes y tratar de
cerrar las órdenes de compra y eso hice
por treinta y tantos días los jefes de
mi mamá cuando mi mamá ya estaba por
salir del coma nunca se imaginaron que
yo me hice pasar por marlene durante
todos esos días cerrando negociaciones
de miles de dólares entre colombia y
laboratorios farmaceúticos en venezuela
no lo digo con orgullo pero fue lo que
hice frente a la crisis
mi mamá en efecto como dijeron los
médicos después de ciertos tratamientos
pudo respirar por sí misma y salió del
coma inducido sin embargo su capacidad
respiratoria no estaba como para
sostener una vida normal y a los dos
meses mi mamá falleció después de la
muerte mi mamá comencé a vivir un nuevo
ciclo y una nueva etapa que era
entenderme en el mundo que iba a ser yo
cómo iba a trabajar cómo iba a resolver
pagar la luz el agua el teléfono estar
solo empecé un ciclo donde comprendí que
significaba estar completamente solo
frente a las decisiones de tu vida en
una etapa muy temprana y lo digo porque
no había mucha familia éramos somos un
núcleo muy chiquito mi hermano y yo mi
hermano se fue a los eeuu con mi papá y
yo quedé en venezuela para terminar mi
carrera un día me da un dolor profundo
como si fuera una apendicitis le
pregunto a una vecina le digo
un dolor muy profundo me dice si subiste
las escaleras hasta acá no debe ser nada
crítico anda dormir me voy a dormir no
aguanto el dolor la fiebre que tenía en
la madrugada y decido llamar un taxi e
irme para la clínica me voy para la
clínica llegamos a la clínica este bueno
ni una tía que tenía fue para allá la
familia de mi novio pero ellos vieron
sobretodo el médico que me trató vio que
yo llegué muy sola a la clínica me opera
y esa operación duró más de nueve horas
antes de la operación el médico me
pregunta mucho sobre mis circunstancias
que comí y qué hacía cómo trabajaba yo
bueno evidentemente les conté vivo sola
estudió comunicación social en trabajo y
estudio porque trabajo para vivir porque
mi mamá no está presente en mi mi papá
vive afuera todo esto se lo conté y aquí
viví uno de los duelos más difíciles con
el que no he sabido todavía mucho que
hacer pero también fue el comienzo otra
nueva etapa en mi vida
resulta que este médico en mi
postoperatorio como fue una operación
tan larga en mi postoperatorio fue
complicado me tuvieron que ver varias
veces hubo una infección etcétera
entonces bueno tenía que ir a las
consultas el mes y está el primero de
mayo cada día del trabajador en la
clínica y me dice que asista yo voy veo
que la clínica está muy sola porque es
el día del trabajador además en ese año
estaban construyendo en esa clínica y
había algunos espacios que estaban
cerrados porque había construcción
justamente el pasillo donde quedaba su
consultorio era uno de los que se estaba
construyendo entro al consultorio él me
está haciendo la consulta normal y en un
momento dado porque no lo vi venir y a
veces las crisis y el caos llega de esa
manera el médico intentó abusar
sexualmente de mí me empuja contra la
camilla y pasan un montón de cosas y
forcejeó este de los cuales no me siento
tan cómoda de explicar
pero gracias a dios no no pudo violar me
pero si se acabó en mi una etapa muy
importante de mi vida
primero jamás pude imaginarme que un
profesional de la salud podría querer
hacer eso como un paciente segundo
entendí lo sola que estaba en ese
momento crítico porque claro si yo
hubiese ido a las consultas con alguien
que me acompañase o si hubiese quizás el
visto que yo no llegué sola a la clínica
sino que había más familia presente
quizás eso no hubiese pasado y entendí
que mi mejor compañero cómplice tenía
que ser yo enfrentar ese duelo después
de haber tenido una familia como la tuya
como la de todos en la que siempre ha
encontrado con un ciclo de un círculo de
ayuda y empezar a vivir una vida donde
dice el círculo ayuda a tu primer
círculo de ayuda tienes que hacer tú fue
uno de mis comportamientos o de mis
conductas condicionadas por este tipo de
situación y no se sientan mal esa fue
una etapa dura y difícil de mi vida que
después me permitió vivir cosas
maravillosas que es aquello de esa
profunda crisis primero ser mi principal
cómplice poder creer mucho y mi
intuición había cosas en el médico que
ya me estaban diciendo que qué bueno que
podía ser peligroso y lejos de
responsabilizar me a mí que sería una
conducta que cualquier víctima de abuso
sexual
responsabilizó 100% a este médico lo que
sí aprendí fue hoy que tengo 35 años y
veo a esa verónica digo wow que es todo
lo que pudimos construir después y como
eso no me derrumbo resulta que bueno con
muchísima esté fortaleza interna
comienzo entonces a decir yo quiero
escribir un capítulo bonito de mi vida
porque yo no controlaba el resto de las
cosas yo no controlaba que mi mamá había
fallecido
yo no controlaba haber vivido este
intento de violación eran cosas que me
superaban eran más grandes que yo
entonces yo decidí que yo quería hacer
yo por mí cosas grandes entonces frente
a esa crisis y frente a ese caos me
enamoré de la idea de hacer algo con
sentido de urgencia que me hiciera feliz
que me despertara pasión y que me
ayudara a construir porque para mí
frente a la crisis si yo no hacía nada
por mí quien lo iba a hacer y la única
tendencia iba a ser a empeorar entonces
decidí armar mi primer proyecto una
revista y miren esto cuando te empiezas
a actuar frente a la crisis y empiezas a
hacer frente a la crisis frente frente a
los duelos frente a los cambios tan
duros de vida que pueden superar te como
es el caso este año de la pandemia cosas
extraordinarias comienzan a pasar tú sin
querer estás trabajando para que cosas
extraordinarias pasen
y pasamos de esa oscuridad que es la
crisis a este momento de luz estoy yo a
mis 20 años con un proyecto en un power
point era mi primera empresa mi primera
empresa era una revista que yo quería
que la gente la consumiera como un medio
impreso que realmente el hablar a los
jóvenes hecho por los jóvenes y para los
jóvenes pero yo estaba trabajando en ese
momento como pasante y como redactor de
varios medios impresos es decir quería
crear un medio impreso nunca antes visto
en comparación con lo que yo estaba
haciendo de trabajo resulta que he
decidido montar en un powerpoint todo mi
proyecto y ahí estaba yo no sabía cuándo
lo iba a hacer pero estaba segura que lo
iba a hacer porque frente a la crisis yo
quería urgentemente crea algo yo crear
luz entonces me voy a una fiesta de
navidad en una empresa de
telecomunicaciones minis empresa
telecomunicaciones era una fiesta en
navidad donde yo tiene que hacer un
reportaje para las revistas en las que
yo trabajaba resulta que ve un señor
super aburrido en esta fiesta estaba
como bostezando como cansado de estar
ahí y lo veo muy solo y yo que siempre
me encantaba hablar con la gente mayor
que yo me senté en esa mesa y empecé a
hablar con él y le dije que tenía un
proyecto que quería hacer porque me
pregunto obviamente que hacía y yo le
dije bueno trabajo en distintos medios
impresos me dijo qué chévere y yo dije
sí pero tengo un proyecto un proyecto
que quiero hacer yo y estas son las
razones por las que lo quiero hacer y
esto es lo que yo he visto la
oportunidad del mercado que hay estaba
tan apasionada contándole de eso que
quería hacer que me dijo por favor
llámame y esta persona era oswaldo
cisneros
el presidente ejecutivo un señor de
negocios muy conocido en mi país el
dueño de la telefónica en donde
estábamos en esa fiesta y me quería
morir cuando me da la tarjeta porque yo
casi que ni creía que él era en verdad
quién decía quién era cuándo me a la
tarjeta que hice oswaldo cisneros
yo digo yo en verdad te voy a llamar
pensando que me lo estaba haciendo por
cortesía y me dijo llámame en enero en
la segunda semana de enero que era
cuando él regresa de vacaciones allí
estuve yo con ese mismo sentido de
urgencia de hacer algo por esa
oportunidad que se me estaba presentando
entonces enamorar a mi proyecto aparecí
la primera semana de enero en su oficina
y me hizo esperar seis horas y media
seis horas y media y no había whatsapp
ni instagram en ese entonces pero yo en
esas seis horas y media las utilice para
preparar mejor mi discurso dije bueno
ahora que no me atienden voy a pensar
mejor cómo voy a convencer a esta
telefónica de que me ayude a financiar
la imprenta con la que voy a imprimir mi
primer emprendimiento ya estuve esas
seis horas y media diseñando que iba a
decir cómo se lo iba a decir porque era
importante escuchando las conversaciones
en la oficina para agarrar dos puntos
donde la telefónica podría beneficiarse
entró en la reunión
reunión de días minutos oswaldo cisneros
decides patrocinar la imprenta por un
año y así es como nace mi primer
emprendimiento frente a la crisis
comienzo yo a generar una oportunidad
valiosísima de propia con un sentido de
gestión de empecé a revertir la
tendencia yo les dije que cuando las
cosas están mal para mí la tendencia es
que si no haces nada tiende a empeorar
pero yo decidí cambiar el rumbo en mi
vida y ahí comenzaron a pasar grandes
cosas gracias a la revista empiezan a
aparecer nuevas oportunidades
extraordinarias lo más lindo de
enfrentar la crisis es que la vas como
es nuevo como es un nuevo ciclo tú la
vas viviendo como algo por descubrir y
si pones todos los días lo mejor para
revertir la tendencia empiezan a
empiezas a traer oportunidades
pepsi una de las marcas más importantes
vio el trabajo que nosotros estábamos
haciendo con la revista y se acercó y me
dijo te quieres convertir en consultor
de nosotros en materia digital porque tú
mercadea su primer producto en lo
digital y así queremos mercadear pepsi
yo tenía 20 años imagínense empezar a ir
a las reuniones en una de las empresas
más importantes en mi país empresas
polar hacer presentaciones frente a las
agencias que donde había gente que tenía
más de 40 50 años y yo estaba ahí a mis
20 años presentando un plan
y aquí es donde nuevamente descubro que
hay que ser tu mejor cómplice frente a
la crisis frente a la crisis una vez que
has decidido actuar comprométete con tu
intuición y tus ideas al cien mil por
ciento porque una vez que tú creas en tu
idea que tú creas en tu intuición que tú
creas en la fuerza con la que estás
enfrentando la crisis otros lo van a ver
también imposible no sentir la fuerza de
alguien que se levanta frente a un
momento crítico aún sin conocer su
momento crítico hay algo en la otra
persona que estaba buscando levantarse
que genera alrededor una fuerza con la
que es imposible no conectar y así fue
como 15 años llevamos esa cuenta son 15
años trabajando con la marca pepsi eso
hizo que creciera en un proyecto de
ciento y tanto de personas
y en el 2020 como le ha pasado a tanta
gente me encontré con una crisis resulta
que este año en este 2020 muchísimas
familias han separado muchos negocios
han cuestionado sus sociedades y ahí
cayó por diferencias después de meses de
mediación societaria mi primer hijo o mi
segundo hijo en la agencia decide que ya
no va a continuar en la sociedad y por
tanto este proyecto estaba por terminar
estaba viviendo un profundo dolor porque
sentía que teníamos visiones distintas
mi socio y yo en ese momento empieza la
crisis nosotros trabajando con universal
studios los parques la pandemia
imposible hacer mercadeo para ese tipo
de cliente muchos los clientes paralizan
la pauta publicitaria y comienza una
crisis profunda en esa sociedad
debilitada por tener dos visiones
distintas no nos podíamos poner de
acuerdo y nuevamente si yo no hacía nada
por por destrancar ese problema la un
la tendencia era que iba a empeorar
entonces nuevamente frente a la crisis
sentido urgencia me levanto y digo algo
nuevo tengo que crear para un nuevo
mercado y este es mi último aprendizaje
los nuevos ciclos los nuevos crisis nos
muestran una nueva visión de las cosas y
tener presente en tu vida una nueva
visión de las cosas te da la oportunidad
de reinvención de proponer cosas nuevas
y el hacer cosas nuevas
te genera un entusiasmo importantísimo
que frente a la crisis es muy útil
porque eres como si estuviera jugando
como si en medio del dolor hubiese
tiempo de crear entonces frente a todo
lo que estaba pasando una sociedad de
una compañía como les dije construida
frente a lo que vamos a hacer decidí ver
qué es lo que el nuevo mundo necesita
y frente a un cambio tan significativo
voltearse y preguntar que necesito yo y
que necesita la gente frente a mi
alrededor frente a estos cambios te
puede dar soluciones extraordinarias y
así fue como cree el bootcamp transforma
tu insta en 21 días jamás me imaginé que
iba a crecer a la escala que creció y en
plena crisis societarias decidido con
sentido de urgencia lanzar un proyecto
que ayude a los emprendedores a
transformar rápidamente sus cuentas para
avanzar en un año donde lo digital iba a
ser lo que reinará en la pandemia
decidió armar algo que realmente el
mercado necesitaba un nuevo mercado era
una nueva verónica frente a un mundo de
nuevas posibilidades y así lo vi y una
vez que ya decidí que iba a ser algo
distinto la tendencia que estaba
empeorando que era mi crisis en mi
empresa empezó a cambiar también la
tendencia
y es en ese curso me preocupe porque
fueron un excelente producto donde la
gente tuviera atención personalizada
donde la gente pudiera sentirse motivada
y esa motivación en mis alumnos esa
oferta hizo que el primer grupo de 200 y
tantos personas se convirtiera en un
segundo grupo después los próximos 21
días de 500 y tantas y luego un grupo de
mil personas para concluir un 2020 con
más de 10.000 alumnos 12 mil
inscripciones jamás me imaginé yo que en
un año de pandemia iba a generar un
proyecto que me ayudara de cero a
construir un equipo de 127 personas que
me pudiera permitir aplicar todas las
aprendizajes de vida en un producto y
hacer ahora una mejor organización de la
que supuestamente tenía que vivir un
duelo y renunciar que era mi empresa
anterior crear una empresa de cero con
toda la energía y toda la experiencia
que ya tenía
es por eso que me encanta abrazar las
crisis y decirle que tienes para
mostrarme que nueva verónica vamos a
comenzar ver pero para eso obviamente
pasas por un tiempo muy duro donde no
puedes sostener un duelo patológico
tienes que decir tengo que cerrar este
ciclo y comenzar a vivir uno nuevo y
colocar toda la energía y toda la pasión
en ese nuevo circo para que cosas
maravillosas pasen este 2020 yo lo
siento maravilloso en mi negocio mi
nuevo negocio ya superó el millón de
dólares facturación en ocho meses jamás
lo vi venir lo que sí puedo decirles es
que frente a todas estas cosas incluso
las que no entiendo como ese médico
utilizó su poder como profesional de la
salud para abusar de una niña de 18 años
y eso no lo entiendo lo único que sí
puedo decirles desde la humildad de
alguien que la toca abrazar las crisis
es que tenemos que hacer nuestros
mejores cómplices para revertir la
tendencia y que las cosas no tiendan a
empeorar
[Música]